Salut on est jeudi et jeudi c'est le jour de je dis un petit peu ce que je veux
ou je dis ce que vous voulez, vous ! Et c'est pour ça que de temps en temps je vous pose une question sur Facebook.
En général je pose la question le lundi pour faire la vidéo du jeudi, et lundi dernier je vous ai demandé
ce que vous feriez si vous aviez le pouvoir de lire dans la tête des gens.
Et là je parle pas de mentalisme, je parle vraiment de lire les pensées des gens instantanément.
Vous avez été au total plus de 150 à répondre. J'ai lu toutes les réponses, je les ai classées,
et je me suis aperçu qu'il y avait 5 groupes qui ressortaient.
5 gros groupes, 5 personnalités différentes, parmi vous.
La première catégorie ce sont les chercheurs : y'en a qui cherchent, parmi vous.
Comme Thomas qui veut essayer de comprendre les femmes.
Et je me dis qu'en cherchant bien Thomas tu  pourrais rencontrer quelqu'un.
Je sais pas moi, par exemple Altaïr, qui cherche à comprendre les hommes.
Du coup vous pouvez faire un duo.
Un espèce de binôme comme ça pour essayer de comprendre l'ensemble des hommes et des femmes.
Allez y ! Lancez les travaux !
Alexis par contre pourra pas être de la partie puisque lui déjà il cherche à se comprendre lui-même.
Ha ha, ça c'est pas mal.
C'est à dire qu'il va écouter ses propres pensées.
Le mec il est malin !
Je propose pour superviser les travaux de Thomas et d'Altaïr
Aline en superviseur.
Parce que, elle, déjà, son but si elle peut lire dans les pensées des gens,
c'est de répondre à la fameuse question : "est-ce que les cons se trouvent cons ?"
Deuxième catégorie mais pas surprenante pour autant,
ceux qui vont se prendre pour Dieu directement.
Il y a des despotes parmi vous maintenant c'est clair.
Alexis, Je me prends pour Dieu. C'est cash.
Florian qui est parti loin loin loin loin loin, puisqu'il veut aller lire dans la tête du Christ Cosmique.
Il faut arrêter avec Sylvain Durif, faut qu'on le laisse tranquille maintenant.
On le laisse tranquille, on ne parle plus de Sylvain Durif.
Troisième catégorie, très sympathique aussi, les malins.
Là c'est la majorité d'entre vous, vous êtes des malins, forcément.
On peut lire dans la tête des gens, qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec ça ?
Marine, elle appelle cash son banquier et elle se met au poker.
J'ai envie de dire normal.
Mais là où c'est flippant c'est qu'une autre Marine se met aussi au poker.
Donc déjà vous serez peut-être à la même table, faites gaffe les filles.
Je pense d'ailleurs qu'au poker vous pourriez avoir de grosses surprises
parce que quand tu joues au poker avec quelqu'un qui débute,
il peut être persuadé d'avoir un bon jeu avec pas grand chose.
En analysant la manière de jouer d'une personne, j'étais persuadé qu'elle était assez forte,
et qu'elle cachait un jeu fort en fait,
donc qu'elle faisait un espèce de bluff inversé pour minimiser son jeu.
C'était tout à fait le cas, sauf que je crois que sa main c'était roi de pique et 8 de coeur.
Il n'y avait rien pour elle sur le flop mais elle se disait que
"Eh, j'ai quand même un roi ! Je pèse dans le game !"
J'écouterais les pensées des hommes politiques et je foutrais le bordel à l'Elysée, plutôt malin.
Monter socialement, la base !
Liam c'est pareil, il fait fortune au poker et au mentalisme.
C'est marrant parce que, je me dis c'est un pouvoir énorme lire dans les pensées
et vous voulez tous jouer au poker. Ou faire du mentalisme.
Moi je lis pas dans les pensées, je fais du mentalisme. Il y a peut-être des trucs encore plus ouf à faire non ?
Comme Florian, lire dans mes pensées à moi pour découvrir mes secrets de mentalisme. Malin.
T'es pas tout seul, puisque Clément veut prendre ma place aussi.
Et dans votre bande à vous, il y a aussi Louis hein.
Alors d'abord, il prend quand même du temps pour contrer le terrorisme.
Et ça je trouve ça bien, bravo !
Et ensuite il prend ma place.
Et enfin les deux dernières catégories.
Il y a les "je ne veux pas de ce pouvoir là"
Et il y a aussi les, les what the fuck !
Je finirai par eux.
D'abord , ceux qui n'en veulent pas.
Alors il y a ceux qui n'en veulent pas mais bon quand même, si je l'ai, je m'en sers un petit peu, hein.
Maelys, en trois phrases, t'as changé complètement de direction.
Je ne savais plus dans quelle catégorie te mettre.
Didier, t'as trouvé la solution, tu pars sur une île déserte.
Mais évidemment, j'ai envie de te dire, je viendrais avec toi.
Mais malheureusement, si je viens avec toi elle est plus déserte...
Et oui
Mais Didier, d'une manière générale je pense que quelle que soit la question
en fait, que j'aurais posée,
tu serais parti sur une île déserte au soleil.
Poulpy, ça te fait flipper, ça je pense que c'est normal.
Fiona pareil, je veux pas du pouvoir.
Mais vous avez raison, parce qu'un grand pouvoir
implique de grandes responsabilités.
Pss
Je fais pas très très bien Spiderman.
Je... J'en ai conscience.
Yohan c'est pareil il en veut pas il va se mettre un casque en aluminium.
Tu sais que c'est une théorie qui existe ça, pour contrer la lecture de pensées,
théorie qui a été développée par "Jeanne fait son cinéma" sur sa chaîne YouTube.
Dimi tu veux fuir dans une zone sans cerveau, ça c'est une excellente idée.
Tu peux m'envoyer un message, j'ai quelques adresses à te donner.
Des manifestations politiques aussi parfois.
Enfin, il y a pas mal de zones que je connais
où c'est sûr et certain, il n'y aura pas de cerveaux.
Ne t'inquiète pas.
Peut-être un concert aussi.
Le mec qui a envie de balancer plein de trucs
mais qui ne dit rien.
Et on termine avec la cinquième catégorie
What's the fuck.
Mais pourquoi avoir pensé à ça
à cette question ?
C'est sûrement la série que j'ai préférée.
Mais vous êtes étranges quand même.
Par exemple, celle-ci, je suis pas sûr que ce soit un WTF au départ.
Devenir champion du Monde du Qui est-ce ?
Peut être une volonté, mais déjà, est-ce qu'il y a des concours de champion du Monde de Qui-est-ce ?
Est-ce que c'est vraiment ça que tu as envie de faire si tu arrives à lire dans les pensées des gens ?
Ou alors oui, mais tu fais un Qui-est-ce de ouf !
Tu fabriques ton propre Qui-est-ce ?
Et tu mets dix mille personnages.
Un million, on s'en fout en fait.
Tu peux lire dans les pensées.
Gagner au loto. Alors ça c'est ce qu'on appelle une fausse bonne idée.
En apparence, c'est une très très bonne idée gagner au loto.
On est tous d'accord là-dessus.
Mais comment tu fais pour connaître les résultats ?
Je... Je me suis posé la question : comment fais-tu pour connaître les résultats ?
Tu lis dans les boules ?
Aucune blague sur cette dernière phrase ne sera tolérée.
Est-ce que tu peux parler à ta grille de loto ? Est-ce qu'elle peut te répondre ?
En fait je vois pas tellement la différence entre lire les pensées ou pas lire dans les pensées avec ça.
Mais c'est une bonne idée !
Lisa, au début, j'ai trouvé ça cool. Elle veut devenir une X-Men.
C'est vachement bien de devenir un X-Men.
D'ailleurs tu n'as pas besoin de savoir lire dans les pensées des gens, pour mettre la tenue.
On t'en prie, mets-nous une photo.
Mais à la fin t'as vrillé. Lire les pensées des autruches n'est pas admis sur cette chaîne.
On laisse les autruches tranquille.
Moi j'aurais trop peur, en fait, que les autruches, elles pensent à des trucs de ouf.
Depuis le départ, genre ce sont de grandes philosophes, ou des grandes matheuses,
Et qu'on ne soupçonne pas ça, chez elles.
Comme quoi, peut-être, il ne faut pas se fier aux apparences.
Rémi, tu es peut-être mon commentaire préféré sur cette question.
J'ai adoré ta réponse.
Parce que tu veux enfin rendre service à toute une communauté ?
Au Monde entier en fait ? Je pense que c'est la réponse la plus belle qui pouvait être apportée.
Je crois que ça pourrait résoudre l'un des principaux problèmes mondiaux existants.
Grâce à toi,
on n'hurlera plus en boîte de nuit pour commander.
Rémi...
merci !
Merci à tous d'avoir répondu à la question sur Facebook.
Vous êtes nombreux à me demander pourquoi je mets que la question sur Facebook.
Pourquoi je la mets pas aussi sur Twitter, sur Instagram, sur Snapchat, sur tous ces réseaux-là, puisque j'y suis.
Je la mets que sur Facebook, simplement pour centraliser toutes les réponses.
Parce que sinon c'est une galère de retrouver toutes les réponses, de les isoler
pour faire le montage. C'est sûrement la vidéo la plus longue, en fait, à monter.
Si vous voulez qu'on continue à faire d'autres vidéos dans ce style-là,
dites-le moi dans les commentaires, ça me fait très plaisir. N'oubliez pas,
je les lis tous, j'y réponds un maximum !
Et puis vous pouvez me le faire savoir en laissant un petit...
Je ne dis rien... Vous allez lire dans mes pensées.
Vous ne le savez peut-être pas, mais j'ai ouvert toutes les vidéos au sous-titrage,
vous pouvez participer à ça. C'est un gros projet, c'est vraiment chouette.
Ça permet d'ouvrir toutes les vidéos aux malentendants.
Très honnêtement, j'ai pas le temps de sous-titrer moi-même.
Là, ça ferait beaucoup trop de boulot, mais voilà, si vous pouvez sous-titrer
ne serait-ce qu'une demi-vidéo de temps en temps, vu le nombre qu'on est,
ça peut aller très très vite, donc merci à ceux qui le font déjà, et peut-être merci à vous,
qui allez le faire maintenant.
Prenez soin de vous. Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo. Merci de tous les partages aussi que vous faites des vidéos.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain Mental Vlog. Ciao !